So we're taking up in October the 30th, 1923, and this is volume 16.
I want you to notice something in the heading.
The soul who lives in the divine will is nourished by the flames of Jesus, no problem there.
The problem is in the next line.
She must be filtered through the most pure light of the divine will filtered.
Okay.
And must be exposed to the rays of its burning and eternal sun so as to be deified.
So there's no way we can be deified without the most horrendous purification.
That's just giving it in simple English.
So if you're walking on cushions, get worried.
Louisa said, "I live always in bitter and with my heart petrified by the pain of the
privation of my sweet Jesus.
I feel I am without life because the one who is true life is not with me.
That means visibly.
He is there all the time.
If he's not there, then the kingdom of God is not within her, is it?
Oh, how often I repeat, tell me, oh, my only and highest good, where did you direct your
steps so that by following them, I may find you?"
Now that's straight out of the song of songs and it's probably chapter three.
I've given it to you a minute times, so I haven't written it down again.
The bride tells all her friends, you know, tell me where he is and I will find him, you
know.
He's very up back to that on Easter Day as well, so that's John 20.
So she did be prepared even to ask the soldiers at the grave if they were there, where Jesus
was.
From afar, I kiss those hands of yours, which with so much love, it used to embrace me and
press me to your heart.
I adore and kiss that face, which so much grace and beauty would let itself be seen
by me and now it hides and is far away from me.
Tell me, where are you?
That song of songs five, eight, which way should I take so as to come and reach you?
Tell me what I should do.
Now, here is the soul unbearably unable to tolerate not having him in the way she had
before.
So that is also Sam 63.
My soul agonizes, okay, for you.
Even my body pines for you like a dry weary land without water, Sam 63.
Yet you told me that you would never leave me and now you leave me.
Jesus, Jesus, come back to the one who cannot live without you to your little daughter to
the poor exiled one.
So what you have there is someone in a very high state of love and not being able to tolerate
the beloved not being present.
And as you've read many times in these writings, Jesus himself says love cannot tolerate separation,
which is cannot do it.
But who can say all my lament and the nonsense that I spoke?
In the meantime, I felt I was losing consciousness, who's present then?
And I saw a dove, I want to give you that song of songs for one, the bridegroom calls
the bride a dove and the dove is all on fire.
So that is divine love, which was agonizing.
What does she do?
She sees herself.
She sees herself symbolically.
And it was agonizing and someone was near, in other words, he doesn't leave her.
Who with his burning breath was feeding the dove with his flames in order to nourish
it, preventing it from taking any other food, holding it tightly and so close to his mouth
that it could do nothing other than breathe and swallow the flames which came from him.
And the poor dove agonized and turned into those flames.
That means turned into divine love.
This is the thing I was pointing out to you in the heading that we have to be filtered
through the most pure light of the divine will.
So the little dove is turned into those flames with which it was nourished.
Louisa said, I was surprised on seeing this and my sweet Jesus moving in my interior.
This year Luke 1721, the kingdom of God is within you.
So moving in my interior told me, my daughter, why do you fear that I might leave you?
In order to leave you, I would have to leave myself.
Why?
Because this is volume 16 and he has told us many times that he and Louisa are one, okay,
which I cannot do.
As much power as I have, I do not have the power to detach from myself.
The same for one who does my will since he becomes inseparable from me.
Now that inseparable thing is the union and it's complete union, okay?
And you can put John 14 20 to 21, you and me and I in you.
You can put Galatians 2 20, I no longer live but Christ lives in me, okay?
So he becomes inseparable from me.
I lack the power to detach from him.
Now throughout all of these writings, Jesus refers to his mother as my inseparable mother.
Now notice we're in volume 16, he's now referring to Louisa as inseparable.
So she has arrived at this extraordinary state and he's trying to explain to her why she's
suffering because she is flung into the divine flames of love.
So since he becomes inseparable from me, I lack the power to detach from him and not
only this, but I keep nourishing him with my own flames.
Now that love is so superior to the love they would have at a lower stage in the ordinary
spiritual life.
And that is so superior from what people have living a purely natural life that somebody
living a natural life would have no way of appreciating the love that Jesus is talking
about here, that there's no way at all.
Quite literally they would say you were living on a different planet.
Have you not seen that of all the fire?
It was the image of your soul.
And the one who was feeding it with his burning breath was, we would say it was me.
And I delight so much in nourishing one who lives in my will with only the flames unleashed
by my heart through my breath.
So those are the flames of divine love.
Wouldn't you know that one who lives in my will must be filtered, oh I hate that word,
it feels terrible?
Because if you want to be filtered it means intellect, memory, will, desires, motivations,
feelings, everything, the senses, everything has got to be filtered.
Now St. John of the Cross tells us that he filters the senses first, that's in the first
purification, and in the second terrible purification it's the purification of the intellect, memory
and will.
And it's so terrible that many people don't allow it to actually continue, they're afraid.
Must be filtered with its most pure light.
Now light can get through anything, you know, you pull your curtains at night and you think
you've got complete darkness, you come down in the morning and the light has managed to
get through the curtains, it can filter through the most extraordinary things.
And to be filtered is more than to be put under a press, that's why I'm emphasizing it.
Now the press you see is a biblical word, so it's either the wine press, you know, or
the press for pressing the grapes to make the wine.
And that's a ferocious experience for the grapes, you know, and he says to be filtered
is much worse than to be put under a press.
Because even though the press smashes everything to pieces, it lets everything out, skin and
seeds which settle down at the bottom and leave always something cloudy.
On the other hand, when something is filtered, especially then, if it is filtered through
the thick light of my will, oh I don't like the word tick, you're not going to get through
that one, are you?
If it's filtered through the thick light of my will, there's no danger that it might deposit
something cloudy, rather everything is clear, similar to the clearness of the light which
has been filtered.
And this is a great honor for the soul who lives in my will, that whether she thinks,
speaks, loves, etc., my will takes on the commitment to filter whatever she does through with the
most pure light.
And this is necessary so that in everything she does, there may be no distinction from
what we do.
So remember all the, the, the, the scriptures I've given to you for the last 16 volumes,
16 volumes.
And that is Hebrews 12, 14, nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God,
do you remember?
Hebrews 12, 14, you've got Isaiah 35, now at this moment I can't remember the verse but
the whole thing is about the redeemed of the Lord and nothing unclean can walk this path.
It's as simple as that.
You also have Revelation 21, it's at the very end, and Revelation 22, speaking about the
New Jerusalem, and both of them said, say that for people not committed to the will
of God, I'm simply using our language, okay, they have to stay outside, they can't be
in the city.
It's as simple as that.
So for those of us who want to be in the city, he's saying that this terrifying filtering
has to go on.
And so as you go on, you will begin to realize that the Lord will get you to notice that
I shouldn't be thinking exactly that way, it should be slightly different.
I shouldn't be wanting that particular way.
I should be wanting something slightly different.
Do you know what I mean?
So you get this adjustment all the time, all the time.
And the more generous you are in responding to it, the heavier he comes on, he gets the
job done, but it can be harrowing, particularly if it's something that you thought was yours
and you had every right to have it, you know what I mean?
And it's part of you anyway, do you know what I mean?
And it's part of your inheritance, and it's in your DNA, and we use all these excuses.
And he says, no, no, no, no, I can get through with your DNA.
And this, this horrendous thing, let me just illustrate this in a story, I might have told
you before.
Many years ago, I had to give her a treat in a community, I won't say where, because
this is going on record.
And when I walked in to give the first talk, I had to approach the room from the back.
And so I had to walk up through the community and then turn around and face them.
The very first person I met was somebody like this sitting on a seat all by herself behind
them all, and she looked up at me and caught my eye, and I caught her eye.
And written all over her face was, forget about it, no hope, another one gone.
So I knew I was written off, it didn't take her ten seconds to write me off.
And so I went up and gave my talk, and went back to, they actually gave me an apartment
that they usually give to priests, and went back to my apartment and I said, Lord, I'm
not going to put the lights on, I'm not going to bed, I'm not going to do anything.
You are going to tell me what's wrong with her, because she has written me off and she
has some desperate need that somebody has to answer.
And I said, since she knows I'm useless, I might as well admit it.
And I said, please tell me for her sake.
So I stayed there and he told me, told me exactly what it was.
So the following morning, when I went in to give my first talk, I had to pass her by
again, and at this time she was just sitting there, you know, I have to sit here.
I'm under obedience, kind of stuff, you know.
And I bent down to her and I said, I want to see you after the talk.
It's urgent.
She looked at me in amazement.
And then I continued on and I said, well, she was on the other foot now.
She got me thinking, now I've got her thinking.
So after the talk, I took her by the hand and I said, you and I are coming for a cup
of coffee.
And because in this apartment, I could make tea and coffee for my guests.
And I sat her down and I said to her, you are wondering why you're here.
She said, absolutely.
I said, it's because you wrote me off last night.
She said, was it that obvious?
I said, yeah, I got it.
I said, I got the message clear as daylight.
And she looked a bit embarrassed and I said, don't be embarrassed.
I said, you made me pray for you, have the night until I got the answer.
She said, did you get the answer?
And I said, yeah.
Or she said, don't give me the coffee then, just give me the answer.
And here was a soul that was absolutely desperate.
She told me she was dying of cancer.
She had a short time to live.
She was in a desperate crisis.
She got to every priest she knew, got no response that she could think of.
That could help.
She said, nobody's able to help me.
And I said, OK, stop.
I can tell you the next sentence.
You think there's something radically wrong with you that you won't be saved and you're
going to meet your God soon.
And that's your problem.
And she said, yeah.
I said, the problem you have, darling, is that you're in the second night.
And the Lord is doing such an absolutely unbelievable purification on your intellect,
memory, and will, and everything.
I said, that you think there's something radically wrong with you.
I said, there's something radically right with you.
And she looked at me in absolute amazement and I said, does that speak to your soul?
And she said, yeah.
And I said, OK.
So what you do now is go to your spear, ask permission to go to bed because you're ill.
Don't come to the retreat.
Nothing that I will say to you on the retreat will speak to your situation.
I said, you're absolutely right in knowing that I couldn't speak to your situation.
And took a huge leap in faith.
And I said, he's coming in a few days and he's coming for his bride.
I said, not in debt, but in marriage, spiritual marriage.
I said, it's private.
It's between the two of you.
I won't go near you, but I will inquire if everything is OK.
We won't leave you on your own.
I said, this is between your superior and you and me and the Lord.
I said, nobody else.
Because we do keep all curiosity away.
She had the most incredible experience about two days later.
And I asked the superior, how was she doing?
And she said, she's sitting up in the bed like a radiant bride.
She said, I said, she is a radiant bride.
She said, I know.
I said, can I go in and just greet her?
She said, yeah.
And I actually knelt down to greet her and I said, told you.
And I told you you didn't need the retreat.
You see, someone at this level of purification,
where everything is being challenged, absolutely everything inside of you is with.
You end up questioning your sanity.
Because you haven't come through yet, do you know what I mean?
And it's only when you come through and the light,
everything comes into the light, that everything, absolutely everything makes sense.
She died a couple of weeks later in an extraordinary joy.
Absolutely extraordinary joy.
It's just that the purification had taken so much out of her that she had got the cancer.
The Lord didn't cure the cancer.
That wasn't what he wanted.
But that was the sign the community needed for them to sort of put their skids on
and move on.
So I said to them, rest of them, would you ever drive your cars a little bit faster?
You're all in the slow lane.
She's in the fast lane, you know?
And then use different images for them, you know, if you're timing a mountain,
wait for heaven's sake, get a bit of help, you're not going up quick enough.
But just seeing her was enough.
She died completely radiant, completely changed.
And that's the only image I have in my head reading this because otherwise it can come
across theoretical.
But I've actually seen it in reality, I've seen it happening in a person's life.
And it's a beautiful thing.
So let's come to the next paragraph and you'll see what happened to her.
The heading I have on the paragraph is transformed into light.
Now, as he was saying this, Louisa said, I found myself outside of myself inside a garden.
Usually a garden is a representation of the church.
And tired, I sat down under a tree to rest.
But the rays of the sun darted through me in such a way that I felt I was burning.
I wanted to go under some other tree, a thicker one, which would produce more shade so as
not to be hurt by the sun, but a voice.
And it seems to me that it was my beloved Jesus prevented me from doing that.
You see, our instinctive reaction is to run away from this kind of thing.
One who lives in my will, he said, must be exposed to the rays of the burning and eternal
sun.
That's light.
In order to live of or out of, we would say, light.
So that they see nothing but light and touch nothing but light.
In other words, you're transformed into light.
So first of all, I want to give you one, John 1, 5, God is light.
So it's transformation in God.
And what's the second thing I want to say?
Yeah, Mount Tabor.
Remember, Jesus was transfigured into light, okay?
He was so full of light on the day of the resurrection that they found it difficult to
recognize that this was the person they knew, okay?
So to live out of light itself, you see nothing but light and touch nothing but light.
Now this leads to the deification of the soul.
Isn't that incredible?
Now, that's all fundamental teaching of the church that Jesus became incarnate in order
to deify us, okay?
Only when the soul is all deified in God, then can it be said that she lives in my will?
So you can see that the rest of us are making attempts, but the living in the divine will
is completely radical.
A very radical change actually happens to us.
And that's why you hear Jesus saying it's a new baptism and all the rest of it.
Rather, come out from under this tree and stroll in this celestial Eden of my will.
Now what does that remind you of?
God strolling with Adam in the cool of the day, Genesis 3, okay?
So that's scanning you thoroughly, oh dear.
In your scan, they really see what's inside of you.
And they expect that the scan won't leave anything there that it doesn't see.
So when the Lord scans us thoroughly, then look how much work he realizes he has to do
in us, you know?
Well, maybe he doesn't in you, but he doesn't in me.
The sun may convert you into light and may give you the final brushstroke of the deification
of God.
You become one with God.
Is that something else?
I began to stroll, Louisa said, and as I was doing disobedience, called me back to myself.
So I want to give you Psalm 104 verse 2.
It says, Lord, you are robed in majesty, you are wrapped in a robe of light, okay?
So that's telling you where we're going.
So I have a VIP on the next one, November the 5th, 1923.
And this is Jesus forms his real life, not mystical life in the soul who lives in his
will as in a living host, his real life.
That means that people living in the divine will allow him to return to the earth to continue
his ministry on the earth.
I was feeling oppressed because of the privation of my sweet Jesus with the addition that the
confessor, because I had not had the trust to open up to him because I was bad.
That means she feels awful, had denied me absolution.
Now I think at her level of relationship with God to be denied absolution is something else.
So having received Holy Communion, I abandoned myself in the arms of the most sweet Jesus
and I said to him, my love helped me.
Do not abandon me.
You know in what state I find myself because of your privation and still, instead of help
creatures add pains upon pains.
Without you I have no one else, either with you or on my own, crying over my heart a lot
of having lost you.
This should push you more, not to leave me alone, that's quietly giving out to him.
To at least keep company with the poor abandoned one who lives dying in her heart exile.
And therefore, since you are the highest priest, give me absolution, I love that.
The confessor refused her absolution and she goes over his head and goes to a higher priest.
I think that's brilliant.
You can tell me that you forgive the sins that are in my soul.
Let me hear your most sweet voice that gives me life and forgiveness.
Now Jesus' response to this is only divine.
And the heading I have for myself is the sacred host.
Now, while I was pouring out my pain with Jesus, he himself made himself seen in my interior.
That's your Luke 1721, the kingdom of God is within you.
And Jesus was inside of it alive and real.
Now you might ask what does mystical mean.
And it means that you are living a highly graced life, very sensitive to the presence
of the Lord, but you're not necessarily having visions and revelations and all the rest of
it.
Someone said recently that mystical means behind the veil, that all of this wonderful stuff
is going on, but there is a veil for you and for everybody else.
In the divine will, he comes to actually live in your soul, no mystical veil.
Is that okay?
Your body is actually the accidents that hold this divine presence, just like the bread
in the sacred host is the accidents that hold the divine presence.
It's just amazing.
My sweet Jesus told me, my daughter, this mirror is the accidents of the bread, which
keep me imprisoned within them.
I form my life in the host, but the host does not give me anything, not one affection, heartbeat,
and not the littlest I love you.
It is as though dead for me.
I remain alone without a shadow of requital.
That's response.
And therefore, my love is almost impatient to go out to shatter this glass, descending
into hearts in order to find in them that response, which the host does not know how
to give me nor can it do so because it's only bread.
But do you know where I can find my true response or requital?
In the soul who lives in my will, as I descend into her heart, immediately I consume the
accidents of the host, have you noticed?
I consume.
In other words, he doesn't wait 15 minutes for the body to consume.
That was the bit I wanted to notice here because I know that more noble accidents, more dear
to me are ready to imprison me so as not to let me go out of that heart, which will give
me not only within, which will give me not only life within itself, but life for life.
I will not be alone, but with my most faithful company.
Now one of the things that's very, very frequent in these writings is that Jesus says he doesn't
want to be alone on the earth.
Most of the rest of us don't either.
Okay, but he doesn't want to be alone.
And hence the leaving him alone in the tabernacle is not wonderful.
We will be two hearts palpitating together.
This is a wonderful thing about adoration.
We will love united together and our desires will be one.
So I remain in her and there I live life alive and real, just as I do in the most holy
argument.
Now we've all long since accepted the real presence in the Blessed Sacrament.
It's quite another matter to say the real presence is in me and the real presence is
in you.
That's the bit we've got to take on board and that's the reality of living in the divine
will.
Okay.
But do you know what these accidents are which I find in the soul that does mine?
It has a mobile phone or if you're mobile phone or if you're mobile phone or if you're
mobile phone.
But do you know what these accidents are which I find in the soul who does my will?
They are her acts.
Really circle that now.
They are her acts done in my volition which more than accidents lay themselves around
me and imprison me but inside a noble and divine prison, not a dark one because the acts done
in my will more than sun illuminate her and warm her.
Okay.
Oh, how happy I feel to form my real life in her because those acts are all divine, aren't
they?
And they create divine lives, don't they?
Because I feel as if I were inside my celestial royal palace.
Look at me inside your heart, he said, how happy I am, how I delight and feel the purest
joys.
And Louisa said, my beloved Jesus, isn't what you're telling me somehow new and singular?
The answer is yes.
That in one who lives in your will, you form your real life.
Isn't it rather the mystical life which you form in the hearts which possess your grace?
And Jesus said, no, no, it's not my mystical life as for those who possess my grace and
to do not live with their acts identified within my volition.
Look at that.
How important that is, their acts not identified.
They do not have sufficient material to form the accidents in order to imprison me.
It would be as if the priest did not have the host and wanted to pronounce the words
of consecration so that there's nowhere for the presence to actually lodge, okay?
He could say them, but he would say them to empty space.
My sacramental life would certainly not have existence.
And this is how I am in the hearts which though they may possess my grace, do not live completely
in my will.
Now, the word you ring there is completely, completely.
And your Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10, which I've given you endlessly, talks about the completely.
You must love the Lord with all your heart, all your soul, all your mind and all your
being, Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
They do not live completely in my will.
That means they're only living partially in the divine will.
I am in them by grace, but not in reality.
Isn't that incredible?
And Ruisa said, "My love, but how can it be that you live life really in the soul who
lives in your will?"
And Jesus said, "My daughter, do I perhaps not live in the sacramental host alive and
real body, blood, soul and divinity?"
Now, there you have the doctrine of the church, absolutely underlined for you.
And why do I live in the host in body, blood, soul and divinity?
Because there is not a will that opposes me.
Now, notice the operative thing there.
And he wants to do the same thing in any person whose will does not oppose him.
That's logical, isn't it?
If I found in the host a will opposite to mine, I would form neither real nor perennial
life in it.
This is also the reason why the sacramental accidents are consumed when creatures receive
me, because I do not find a human will united with me in such a way as to want to lose its
will in order to acquire mine.
That's to substitute one for the other.
But I find a will that wants to act, that wants to do things on its own.
In other words, I decide to do them and for my reasons.
So that's the human will dominating there.
So I make my little visit and I leave, and that's very sad.
On the other hand, for one who lives in my will, my volition and hers are one.
And if I do this in the host, how much more can I do it in her?
More so since I find a heartbeat, an affection, my return and my interest, which I do not find
in the host, to the soul who lives in my will, my real life within her is necessary, otherwise
how could she live in my volition?
You see, the will is the highest faculty that we have, isn't it?
The thing that operates your entire life.
Well, the will is the highest faculty in the divinity, the operating part of the Blessed
Trinity.
And Jesus says, "If my will is going to be a new, I have to be there, because that's
the central part of me."
So we can't have two centers of power, one fighting the other, the human will and the
divine will.
One has to give away to the other.
And so that's why it's his real life, it's not just grace.
Now in dealing with the spirituality, before you come to the divine will's spirituality,
it's all grace.
And if you go deep into it, it's mystical union, okay.
When you come into the divine will's spirituality, it's not that it is similar to the sacramental
host that he is actually living in us, and we become the accidents that hold this divine
presence.
Is that okay?
So, to the soul who lives in my will, my real life within her is necessary, otherwise
how could she live in my volition?
You don't want to understand that the sanctity of living in my will is a sanctity completely
different from all other sanctities.
This has to be repeated over and over because the priests who are guiding Louisa are only
learning this as Louisa learns it.
They don't have this information before her.
And so they can't say to her, "This is how you respond to this kind of message."
They're hearing it for the first time.
So in a lot of the dialogue that we're reading, I hear the dialogue that's going on between
the priests and Saint Louisa, you know, you'd need to really ask a clarification on this
and so on.
So there's something that's terribly important for us to tell people that we teach that this
sanctity is very different to all other sanctities.
And this sanctity takes off where the other sanctity, sorry, yeah, this sanctity begins
where the other sanctities end.
Except for the crosses, the mortifications and the necessary acts of life we're done
in my will embellish the soul more, it's nothing other than the life of the blessed
in heaven.
Now, he has told us that numerous times that to live in the divine will on earth is to
live the life that the blessed are living in heaven, except that we're still on the earth
and we still have suffering and so on.
Who because they live in my will and by virtue of the divine will, have me within each one
of them as if I were there with them alone, alive and real and not mystically but really
dwelling within them.
Okay.
Now, he's emphasized that enough, hasn't he?
And just as this could not be called the life of heaven, if it did not have me with
within them as their own life and their happiness would be neither complete nor perfect, if even
a tiny particle of my life were missing in them, oh, have you noticed that bit?
It wouldn't be complete, if even a tiny part of his life is missing, therefore the suffering
and the passion cannot be missing, a Christian without a crosses and anachronism.
So even it couldn't be complete or perfect if a tiny particle of my life were missing
in them.
In the same way, for one who lives in my will, my will could be neither full nor perfect
in her.
Perfect is complete needing nothing else because my real life which amidst this will
would be missing.
So he is where his will is, if I can put it that way, and his will is where he is.
It's true that these are all projities of my love, even more the prodigy of projities
which my will has kept within itself until now, and which it now wants to issue in order
to achieve the primary purpose of the creation of man, therefore my first real life I want
to form in you because she's the first.
On hearing this, Louisa said, "Am I love, Jesus?"
Yet, I feel so bad because of all these contrasts and you know it.
It's true, you know it is Psalm 139.
You know my thoughts before I tink them on my words before I say them.
It's true that this serves me to abandon myself more in your arms and to ask from you what
they do not give me.
But in spite of this, I feel a breath of disturbance.
Now you were told in Volume 1, no disturbance of any kind is tolerated.
Why is that?
Because if there is disturbance in the depths of your soul, that gives the enemy a tiny
little entry point.
So I feel a breath of disturbance that troubles the peace of my soul.
And you are saying that you want to form your real life in me and he has just said even
if a tiny bit is out, it's not going to work, "Oh, how far I am from this," she said.
And Jesus said, "Daughter, do not worry about this."
What I want is that you put nothing of your own into it.
It's nothing of the human, the earthly and so on.
And that you obey as much as you can.
Now I absolutely love that statement because sometimes you can only obey as much as you
can in a little way and in other times it can be in a big way.
It depends on the pressures that are on you outside and inside as to how much response
you can give.
So as much as you can, it is known that all other sanctities, that is, those of obedience
and of other virtues, are not exempt.
Watch this from pettiness, disturbance, conflicts, waste of time, which prevent the forming of
a beautiful sun.
Now here Jesus is admitting that people we've canonized had real faults.
I don't know if that consoled you.
But one of the things I used to hate when I was younger, reading lives of the saints
and they were written as if the person was just blue, perfect.
And if you do that, I just throw the book there and say, "That's not to do with me."
Give me somebody who had a real problem and worked their way out and that will help.
St. Bernadette of Lords is supposed to have said one time in answer to a question when
she was ill.
She was reading a life of a saint and one of the sisters in her community asked her,
"What have you learned from this?"
She said, "Nothing."
She said, "You've learned nothing from a saint?"
She said, "No."
She said, "If the author had written the sins of the saints, the rest of us could learn
to know what to do with them."
She says, "If you write the thing, absolutely perfect, it's nothing to learn."
Whereas if you see somebody struggling from one position to another and you can see how
it actually works out and how grace comes in at a particular point, then you have a key
to dealing with something in your own life, your own.
And there's only very great people like Jeremiah and St. Paul who could tell you their faults.
I love in Paul's confession in 1 Corinthians 7.
The things I want to do, I don't want to do, and the things I don't want to do, I find myself
doing.
Thanks for God he was human, you know, because then that gives you an understanding of yourself,
which is actually terribly important.
So these sanctities were not exempt from pettiness, that's interesting, disturbance, conflicts
and waste of time, wait, that's brilliant.
I don't know about you, which prevent the forming of a beautiful sun.
At the most they form a little star.
Only the sanctity of my will is exempt from these miseries.
And besides, my will encloses all the sacraments and their effects.
Now note this, therefore, abandon yourself completely in my will, make it your own and
you will receive the effects of the absolution or of anything else that you might have been
denied.
I got that message, did you?
Are you absolutely sure you got it?
Let me read it again.
Besides, my will encloses all of the sacraments and their effects, therefore, abandon yourself
completely in my will and make it your own.
And you will receive the effects of the absolution which she had asked for, do you remember?
Or of anything else that you might have been denied.
So supposing a terrible storm comes and none of us can get a mass and you can't do this
that and the other.
You can clock into the whole thing in the divine will.
It doesn't mean that you don't go to mass in normal times, but there are times when he
says when something is denied you that you can, in the divine will, you can access it.
I think that's fantastic.
So I recommend to you, don't waste time because by wasting time, you come to hamper my real
life which I am forming in you.
That's a wonderful piece, isn't it?
So November the 8th, 1923.
When Jesus came on earth he observed, perfected and abolished the ancient laws in order to
establish the new law of grace.
Now that is the most perfect summary of the Old Testament.
It's the most perfect summary of the Old Testament.
When did Jesus finally abolish the law?
Wasn't it on the cross?
Yeah.
And what was the sign that the veil of the temple split into indicating that the covenant
of Moses was finished?
In the same way, watch this now because it's terribly important because you've been told
that to be told something else, okay?
So in the same way, Louisa suffers in the divine will all the interior states present
on the path of human sanctities.
He gives completion to them and gives rise to the sanctity of the divine will.
Now since Louisa is the one to be the first to live the divine will, we're not talking
about a blessed lady and Jesus, and to start the kingdom of the divine will, everything
in terms of sanctity that has been done before then has got to be relived, read on, completed,
finished and opened up to the new thing.
That's the logic.
We aren't expecting that, were we?
Take real note of that, okay?
And I would put a VIP on that one because that is not something you hear people talking
about probably because they'd be afraid of the kickback, you know?
They were to kill Jesus sooner if he had told them that he was completing the law of Moses.
So Louisa said his privations continue, "At the most he comes like fleeting flesh, and
while it seems that it may want to make light, one remains in the dark more than before."
Now, while I was swimming in the bitterness of his privation, my sweet Jesus made himself
seen in my interior, that's your Luke 1721, all busy writing.
Now writing is not something you really associate with him, do you?
Not with a pen, but with his finger, which emitted rays of light, and that light served
him as a pen in order to write in the depths of my soul.
Now, beside that I want you to put Jeremiah 31, 33, Jeremiah 31, 33.
He will write it on your heart, okay, which is exactly what he's doing.
But for the Bible it means your person.
I wanted to tell him who knows how many things about my poor soul.
But putting his finger on his lips, he made me understand that I should keep silent, for
he didn't want to be distracted.
And then after he finished, he told me, "Daughter of my supreme volition.
I am writing in your soul the law of my will, I will write it on your hearts."
That's what the Lord said to Jeremiah.
The new covenant will be written on our hearts so that everybody would know interiorly, okay.
First I want to write it in your soul and then little by little I will explain it to you.
This is where you can ask for the gift of the divine will and later on you come to understand
it bit by bit by bit.
And in Louisa said, "My Jesus, I want to tell you of the state of my soul, oh, how bad
I feel.
Why do you leave me?"
Now he's trying to tell her something absolutely extraordinarily important and she's back
to me.
Isn't it amazing?
This is us.
And Jesus said, "Do not afflict yourself, my daughter.
You must know that when I came upon the earth, I came to abolish the ancient laws."
Look at that.
This is clear as daylight and I came to perfect others, okay.
But in abolishing them, I did not exempt myself from observing those laws.
He observed the law of Moses perfectly and the Gospels go out of their way to say, you
know, that such and such an obligation he actually fulfills it.
Do you remember the case where somebody asked Peter, "Does your master pay the half shekel?"
And he paid the half shekel.
And but Jesus said, you know, there's actually no obligation on us to do it.
We belong to a different kingdom, a different sphere.
But we must have scandalized until we pay the half shekel.
Rather, he said, "I observe them in a more perfect way, it's a more complete way than
others did."
But having to unite the old and the new within myself, I wanted to observe them in order
to give completion to the ancient laws.
In other words, the law of Moses came from God and Jesus was the only one who fulfilled
the law perfectly because he was divine as well as human.
So all of God's obligations in the Mosaic law were fulfilled by Jesus.
So placing on them the seal of their abolition and to give rise to the new law.
Now there's a huge answer here to many Christians who through charismatic prayer groups have
come under the influence of evangelical Christians.
And they come to be told, yes, you do have to obey the laws of Moses.
There's absolutely no way you can eat pig meat, for example.
That's totally absolutely according to the law of Moses.
You Catholics don't keep the shabbat on the right day, it's on a Saturday, it's not on
a Sunday.
And what they're doing is they're going back into the Mosaic law which has been abolished.
It's finished.
And you don't go back to something that's dead and gone, you have to leave it there.
So it's terribly important what he's saying here, "I placed on them the seal of their
abolition and to give rise to a new law."
So he's talking here about the old law versus the new.
Now of course, the teaching for us is the old sanctity versus the new.
And of course you automatically go back to what you know.
And we slip back into that without even knowing we do it.
So I came to give rise to the new law which I came to establish on the earth, a law of
grace and love.
By which I enclosed all sacrifices within myself, you see, he completes the whole sacrificial
system.
Since I was to be the true and only sacrificed one, therefore all other sacrifices were no
longer necessary and the evangelicals are correct on that one.
But they misunderstand the mass completely.
Because I being man and God, this was more than sufficient to satisfy for all.
Now you will get that summary that's been given to you there.
You will find in the letter to the Hebrews, chapter 12.
The letter to the Hebrews, chapter 12, verses 18 to 29.
Same teaching, okay.
Now he's not telling that to us to tell us about the old law and the new law because
that was established 2000 years ago.
He's telling us that to help us to go over from the old sanctities to the new sanctity.
Okay.
So this is what you're going to get in the next paragraph, the old sanctities, verses
the new one.
Now beloved daughter of mine, wanting to make of you a more perfect image of myself and
to give rise to a new sanctity, now where the images of God is Romans 829.
And to give rise to a new sanctity, so noble and divine.
Now what's different is the divine, which is the Fiat Vellontas to a secret in Teilot
et Intera.
I want to centralize in you all the interior states which have been until now on the path
of sanctity.
This is why Louisa goes through so many Agonies and she doesn't know whether it's winter or
summer or whether she's growing or whether she's going backwards.
And he is trying to give her something absolutely extraordinary and she says, "But I'm so bad."
Do you know what I mean?
And it's this thing that she has to actually experience all the spiritualities leading
up to then.
So she has to go through penance and fervor and all of John of the Cross stuff and tree
survivalist stuff and everything.
It's horrendous, absolutely horrendous.
But it explains the extraordinary variety that she actually experiences.
So you have to experience all the interior states which have been until now.
And as you suffer them and move on, now the bit that's difficult for us is moving on.
Okay?
So I have to put an envy for myself and for others who lived on the spirituality of John
of the Cross all our lives and that is you have to move on from John of the Cross and
tree survival and on to the spirituality of the divine will.
That's not easy if your whole life as mine was was based on this Carmelite spirituality.
And you have to suffer them and you have to move on doing this in my will.
And I give completion to them.
That means they're finished.
Now we have a problem, haven't we?
Am I the only one thinking of the problem or have you thought of it as well?
That means you can't go back to the old sanctities to learn from them.
They're finished.
I give completion to them and they can only tell you where they are at.
And I've said to people, look, I know this sounds terrible, but John of the Cross and
tree survival were the 16th century, were the 21st and the church has actually grown.
They might not think it was actually grown in that length of time and has grown an understanding
of all kinds of things.
And people find it, Carmelites would have me strung from the first tree for saying that.
I crown them and embellishing them, I give them the seal.
That's the seal of completion.
You only seal a scroll when it's finished, you roll it up, seal it and put it away.
Everything must end in my will because all of these people who had all of these sanctities
had to end up in the divine will in heaven.
But they didn't have the divine will until they got to heaven, is that okay?
And there were other sanctities end, the sanctity of my will being noble and divine has all other
sanctities as its footstool.
And that's where you have its beginning.
And that's where a lot of us, including myself, have really struggled.
How you go from the older sanctities to the new one.
Because the problem is you don't know enough about the new one to shift from where you
are.
Okay.
Therefore, let me do that, give me the freedom to work.
Let me repeat my life and that which I did in redemption with so much love.
Now with greater love, I want to repeat it in you to set the beginning that my will and
its laws may be known.
But I want your will united to and dissolved in mine.
Now, that actually requires a good bit of thinking and going over unless you're an awful
of better than me.
I'm going to leave it there for tonight.